look at shy shy is right that's Kim
Kardashian and Kanye West's one-year-old
daughter Chicago playing with yes you
guessed it a living breathing snake at
one point she even looked the reptile
dead in the eye while it's wrapped
around her neck
Kim shared the video on Instagram and
gushed about her brave girl in the
caption I love that the mom of four has
been sharing adorable photos with her
children all week including this snap of
her making funny faces with
three-year-old son Saint there's also
this hilarious photo montage of six year
old North giving some major Sinai while
cradling baby brother Psalm she
definitely has Kanye's outgoing
personality and will say whatever is on
her mind no matter what it is or who it
might offend and then she's also really
common sweet like me sometimes and how
cute are these photos of Kim posing it
up on the beach with all four of her
kiddos the girls all rockin matching
swimsuits and the caption I thought
taking a pic with three kids was hard oh
my god this is almost impossible why
honestly feels so content speaking of
vacation Kim's sister Chloe has also
been posting a slew of pics from their
Bahamas getaway including this series of
snaps of her daughter true wish Chicago
and the hilarious caption vacation
calories don't count we're definitely a
close family like more than probably
normal
[Applause]
you